-And now,
President Donald Trump.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank me. Thank me very much.
You're all very happy that
I'm here at the United Nations.
I mean, wow.
Just look at all of
the room full of
diverse cultures
and ethnicities.
Seriously, it's like
the scariest college brochure
I've ever seen.
But I know what
you're all thinking --
it's so great to be here with me
for the last 4 to 6 hours
of my presidency.
Who knew?
You make one phone call
blackmailing a foreign leader,
and everyone acts like you
made one phone call
blackmailing a foreign leader.
I guess it's like
the old saying.
Collude once, shame on you.
Collude twice,
why not collude a third time?
But now it looks like
my whistle's been blown,
and not in the good way.
It was a low-down blow-down.
And now I'll have to
face off against America's
least-fun grandma, Nancy Pelosi.
That's right -- Nancy's gone
totally Ukraine in the membrane.
But, luckily, she has
no evidence against me --
only calls and transcripts
and the fist pump
I just gave the Ukrainian
president on my way up here.
Hey, what's up, buddy?
But unfairly for me,
Ukraine isn't my only
big no-no this week.
Apparently, people are still mad
because I left
yesterday's climate summit after
just 15 minutes.
But, honestly, folks,
how do you expect me to believe
in global warming
when they just filmed
the second "Frozen" movie?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, seriously, let it go.
But, anyway, back to
"The Witch Hunt: Season 3."
I just want to --
All my supporters --
I want them all
to just relax, okay?
Because as hard as people
try to impeach me,
I'll always be
one step ahead of them,
trying to impeach me harder.
But, anyway, in collusion...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...America's the
greatest country on Earth,
Ukraine owes me a serious fave,
and you might call it
climate change,
but I call it Hot Girl Summer.
Oh, and one more thing.
"The Tonight Show" is coming to
you live from New York City!
Let's start the show, baby!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪